now if you've been watching my channel
this video is probably not for you
but it's for your friends and family that
eat carbohydrates because we know you
are on the ketogenic diet so if you have friends
and family that are not on the ketogenic diet
you can show them this video but the question
is why do people crave salt after they eat
sweet or even after they eat some carbohydrate
we're going to talk about why that is
so let's say for example your friend not you
eat some cake drink some soda eats candy cookies
a donut ice cream and then later that day or
night start craving some salt they need some
chips right they need something salty why is that
because when you start getting high blood glucose
there's too much sugar in the blood
sodium starts leaking out of your cells
because of what glucose does to the cell it's very
osmotic which i don't want to get into the details
on the mechanism but just realize that when you
have high glucose in your blood you tend to lose
sodium in certain places in the body and
you also become deficient in potassium
so you have hyponatremia which is low sodium
and hypokalemia which is low potassium
now the symptom of low sodium would be you crave
salt and you can actually develop a headache or
have adrenal stress you can feel more stress and
this is why sometimes when people eat more salt
they they feel calm they can actually relax and
their cravings go away their headaches go away at
least for a minute but what are the cravings for
low potassium there is none you're not going to
crave a big salad after this event are you usually
not because there's no cravings when you're low in
potassium even though you should be consuming a
high potassium food like a big salad people don't
the ratio of sodium to potassium should be one to
two you should always have twice as much potassium
so here's a person who eats the carb
then they eat the salt they satisfy this
but they don't satisfy potassium because
when you actually just have more salt
without the potassium you create even more of a
deficiency of potassium if you look at the ratios
and then all sorts of other things will happen
you may get palpitations you may feel this loud
pounding in the ear inner ear like your
heartbeat is like that on the pillow when
you're trying to sleep you're going to have a hard
time sleeping because potassium is a physiological
tranquilizer it relaxes you potassium also gives
you energy so you may feel fatigue you may feel
out of breath when you're going up the stairs
potassium also is involved with preventing leg
cramps because it's an electrolyte and it's needed
in the muscles for various things so for those of
you that are on carbs you don't want to forget
about this potassium to take that either in a
supplement or an electrolyte or just a large
salad but for those of you that are regularly
watching my videos you don't have to worry about
this whole thing because you're not eating carbs
so you're not going to develop these issues right
here because you're doing the healthy version
of keto but if you're not on keto and you want
to know how to do this i put a link down below
and i'll explain exactly how to do the healthy
version of keto and in a minute fasting so if
you're enjoying my content which i hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to your health
and you have a success i'd really appreciate you
sharing your success story so click the link down
below to my website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire others